Do you want to know what it is like to
be an international model
the real lifestyle, the traveling, well
I have just arrived at my new modeling
contract let me share my model lifestyle
with you
To be an international male model you need
to be able to travel a lot you need to
go to a new country for two to three
months and stay there until your
contract is finished right now I'm on my
way to my new contract China
yo guys
good morning what's up so I've been here
in China for a couple of weeks and I'm
just gonna show you how a normal day
would look like for a model here in
China. Saturday yeah we have to work on
weekends
so I'm on my way to castings but before
then I'm just gonna stop at the agency
and show you how that looks like
so this is my model agency here in
Guangzhou China models international
I came in here just to see the options or
the jobs that I have for this week
so here we have all the models and then
here's my card over here.
So the model card is like a very small CV
so when you go to the castings you give
this to the client and if they're
interested in you then they will call
back the agency and they will book you
for a job so China just like most
countries in Asia you cannot go to the
castings by yourself you need Booker's
to go with you that can translate
because you don't know their language
right so this is the A team in
Guangzhou best models in town
and every day when we go to castings, he
brings the food to the car
It's like really healthy food, chicken some beans, white rice
and some tomato with salad. See the model lifestyle, we have to eat and stay healthy
this is Eric, our new Booker, he is taking us to the castings
and then Jesse or Jesse James
in the front
hey okay, Ni hao! All right so that's the
team
this is our first casting for the day so
on the left is the models and on the
right side you have the clients how it
works is that the clients will choose which
models they like and those models they
have to do some poses for the clients
this is the fourth agency and finally
this is us. Now you see there's a lot of
models in town so the competition is
quite tough so it's not that easy to get
a job. All right, so the client chose me and
they wanted me to do some poses here so
that's what I'm doing I'm fitting the
clothes and I'm doing some poses with
the clothes and the client will
look to see if they're happy with it or
not.
They can not see you
this is our second casting for the day
let's do this.
First up is Nicholas.
Michael is next
this is Karen
this is Joseph.
This is Martin
and I'm
next guys
so we are five models in this agency
however we are different ages and we do
have different styles
Let's go home
and
there we go home
here we go
alright so that is it for the castings today
Cheers guys
hey guys I'm having a haircut
and they they massaging my, my head
it's, anyway, it's too good to talk to you
talk to you later.
for us models who travel around the
world it's pretty hard to find a
hairstylist that you can trust so in
China this is the only guy I can trust
his name is Mike
So one of the coolest
things about being a model is that you
travel and you see these different
cultures. You live with these people and
see how they live every day
I want this.
How much is this?
Thank you
so this is how I do my shopping here in
China
How much is it together?
Halo, how are you?
Good
DO you have 1?
1?
Yes
How are you?
I like this
I want a little.
Ok
How much money?
Good!
Very good!
Thank you
thanks for watching the video! If you
liked it. Please give me a like and a
thumbs up and subscribe to see some more
videos